I went to New Palestine you know when
the terrible thing happened there
because I saw them as representative of
our people
the people that voted for Trump the
people that voted Republican in 16 the
people who have been uh not taken
seriously the people have been rejected
the people who are called deplorable I
actually saw a little Petey
buddha jug oh man he actually showed up
because I went there and because Trump
went there and we watched him my my uh
colleague Chad and I we watched him
the the mayor who asked me to come and
the police chief let him wait for 45
minutes outside and continue the
conversation with me about the most
irrelevant things I was there to advise
them on how to deal with the crisis
because they wanted to just screw him
you know give him a hard time well when
you went to see him outside he put
himself in a place that he didn't have
to be near any of these people these
dirty people
these dirty hard-working people who
mostly are descendants of coal miners
and they you know they're not dressed
properly and they're not
and that's those are the people who put
Trump in office the people the rejected
people so it may be that that isn't
there right now or it may be there but
he ran at exactly the right time
and uh
I think DeSantis is going to run and I
think
he's good he probably feels this is it
so if you like this clip and you want to
watch another one click right here and
if you want to watch the entire podcast
click right here
[Music]